ROY FULLER: Ready to roll.
NEVIN HEINTZE: All right.
Thanks very much, Roy.
And thanks, everyone,
for your time.
And welcome to this
session on Spanner POCs.
I'm Nevin Heintze.
I'm a Senior Engineer at
Google on the Spanner team.
So today, we're
going to discuss how
to plan and run a Spanner POC.
And the talk is
roughly in three parts.
First, we'll talk
about POCs in general,
why you want to do a
POC, what would you
learn from it, what are
some of the typical goals,
and how you plan one.
And next, to make this
a bit more concrete,
I'm going to walk
through an example
of some typical steps in a POC.
And I'm going to use
this using sample gaming
application that's loosely
based on NFL fantasy football.
And then part 3, I'll conclude
with some observations
on best practices
and tooling and then
open it up for questions.
All right, so let's
take some context first.
So if we zoom out
a little, then it's
useful to recognize
the role of a POC
as part of the big picture
of the Spanner migration.
So usually, the POC is fairly
early on in a migration.
I've got on this slide a typical
set of steps of a migration.
And not all migrations
have exactly these steps
in exactly this order.
But in general, this
flow is pretty common.
These steps are fairly
independent of the source
and target databases.
And I'm sure for some
of you, these steps
will be pretty familiar.
What I'm going to do
is go over these steps
and highlight them from the
perspective of migrations
to Spanner.
So most migrations start with
some kind of assessment phase.
So the goal here is to
determine if the target
database, in this case, Spanner,
is likely to be a good fit.
Will it provide the
necessary functionality?
Will it meet cost
performance requirements?
How much work will
the migration be?
What are the biggest risks?
What are the biggest benefits?
So the next step is
often a proof of concept.
And in many ways, this is like
an extension of the assessment.
So it's typical for
the proof of concept
to focus on key items that
came up in the assessment,
like the biggest
risks or confirming
the main benefits
can be delivered.
So a proof of concept is
often like a feasibility study
for the full migration.
We want to use it as a
vehicle to understand,
to explore key technical
issues and tradeoffs,
and basically to
set up a blueprint
for the rest of the migration.
All right, so what are
the remaining steps
of a migration after POC?
And I've split this into a
couple of steps on this slide.
So in step 3 on this
slide, it's kind
of the core part of the
migration preparation,
so design, implementation
of the migration.
So, you know, this can
have many components.
And there's some
common themes here--
designing Spanner
schema, figuring out
how to move data from
your current database
into Spanner,
building components
to support that
move, and the third
is application changes to
switch over to using Spanner.
So it's typical to
prototype approaches
to much of this work in the POC.
Now the next step, step 4,
is testing and dry runs.
And successful migrations
involve significant testing,
either using test traffic or
parts of your production load.
And it's common for steps
3 and 4 to be intermixed.
So you might have an initial
design and implementation,
try it out, find issues,
go back, do some redesign,
change the implementation.
So this is really an
iterative process.
And finally, many migrations
have kind of a target day
for moving data or
completing a data move
and switching over
to using Spanner.
So this is a really critical
day of a convergence
of all of the
planning and execution
phases of a migration.
And a key part of
this is knowing
how to respond if things
don't go according to plan.
What signals and dashboards
should we be looking at?
What's the criteria
for reverting?
How do we revert?
So if you'd like to hear
more detailed discussion
of migration, then you
might be interested
in the talk in a previous Cloud
Spanner meetup back on July 22
on exactly this topic.
But today, we're going
to focus on POCs.
And I'm going to start
with the kind of core
question, why do we do a POC?
So as I mentioned
earlier, in many ways,
a POC is an extension of
the assessment phase, a kind
of in-depth, hands-on analysis.
So what drives the POC is
usually the open issues, items
of concern from the assessment.
So what you want to
get out of the POC
is confidence that the
migration will work
and that it will
be cost effective.
So typically, you're looking
to derisk core issues.
Those might be
related to handling
of load, performance latency.
And we'll look into this in
more detail in the next slide.
Or you might want to validate
the main benefits you think
you'll get from Spanner,
so to confirm that Spanner
will scale to your workload.
So POCs, as I mentioned
earlier, are often
a mini dry run of a migration.
They help identify issues
you might have missed.
And they provide data to better
plan out the full migration.
Another key role
of POCs is sizing.
So how large will your
Spanner instance need to be?
How will you manage sizing for
peak versus drops in traffic
and so on?
So typically, I'm going
to have some time where
I have way more traffic and, at
other times, significantly less
traffic.
How am I going to manage those
peaks and troughs in traffic?
So data from a POC is
often critical to coming up
with accurate costing estimates.
And finally, POCs serve to
help you learn about Spanner
and use it effectively.
So let's talk about
some concrete goals.
Probably the most basic
and frequent POC goal
is a very fundamental one--
does Spanner scale
to my use case?
Now, as I'm sure
many of you know,
a Spanner database is not
just a single machine or even
a couple of machines.
It's hundreds, thousands, and
in some cases, tens of thousands
of machines working together
to provide a massive, strongly
consistent database.
So the ability to harness
a mass of machines
and make them behave
like one system
and at the same time support
serialized asset transactions
in SQL--
it's really one of the
defining properties of Spanner.
Now, many customers want
to see that in action
and understand how
it'll work for them.
And POCs are a really
good way to do that.
A related question
is load surges.
Can Spanner scale up
to surges and then
scale back down again
when there's less load?
How quickly does this happen?
And operationally,
what does it look like?
Next is latency.
Many POCs focus on latency
for key operations.
They could be reads or writes,
some kind of analytic queries,
or a combination
of all of these.
And you may have particular
latency percentiles
that you want to achieve,
maybe a 90th or 95th percentile
or 99th percentile.
So again, this can be
another key goal of a POC.
Another common question is,
how many nodes do I need?
So this really
represents a tradeoff.
You can run Spanner a bit
hotter and use less nodes
but see slightly higher
latency and have less headroom.
Or you can run
Spanner a bit cooler
and use more nodes but see lower
latency and have more headroom.
Now, we strongly recommend
keeping Spanner utilization
for high-priority
operations under 65%.
But it's not uncommon to see
utilization around 35% to 50%
because of the latency and
headroom benefits it delivers.
All right, so POCs
can also be used
to understand the scope
of application changes
that might be needed
in a migration.
So what code changes
will I need to make
to move from, say, MySQL
or Postgres to Spanner?
Usually, the focus is on key
components of an application.
And the goal of
the POC is to get
that particular specific
component running on Spanner.
And the reason for
doing that is we
don't want to get all of
the pieces of an application
running during the POC
because that's just
going to be too much work.
Finally, a POC can be used to
investigate schema tradeoffs.
For example, what
indexes should I use?
How will they impact
my read latency?
And moreover, how
will the indexes
impact my write latency?
OK, a couple of high-level
comments on planning a POC--
so it's really
important to establish
a clear scope for a POC.
Don't try to address all
issues or solve all problems.
So it's critical
to limit the scope
to just several important
issues, maybe three or four
issues.
And of course, having
well-defined and realistic
success criteria is important.
Now, usually, you want
to take a core component
of your application stack
as the focus of the POC.
It could be your main workload,
maybe your highest QPS workload
or the workload you're most
concerned about for one
reason or another.
And that drives the
implementation part of the POC.
So the goal here is to
get that component up
and running on Spanner.
Or maybe you'll build a mock of
that part of the application,
modeling key aspects of
that application component
and get that running on Spanner.
The main part of a
POC will typically
be running this
component against Spanner
using sample traffic.
You might have production
traffic that you can replay.
Or maybe you already
have a load generator.
Or perhaps setting
up a load generator
will be a core part of your POC.
For this, it's common to use
tools like JMeter or Locust
as load generators.
All right, we're now
going to switch gears,
and I'm going to make
all of this more concrete
by looking at a sample POC.
And I'm going to
use a fantasy sports
game as a running example.
And in particular,
I'm going to base
this on NFL's fantasy football.
I suspect some of
you are already
quite familiar with this.
But many of you won't
be, so I'm going
to start out by
briefly introducing
some of the game structure
to get us up and going.
I'm then going to
discuss our POC goals
and describe the
schema we'll use.
And then I'm going
to do a brief recap
on some of the
internals of Spanner
that are going to be
relevant to the POC
that we're going to run.
And then I'm going to
discuss three experiments.
We're going to run and
So let's get started.
So he's a one-pager on
NFL fantasy football.
It's somewhat oversimplified
to fit on one slide,
but it has the core
parts of the game.
So basically, at the start
of the season, you as a user
playing this game, you get
to pick a team of 16 players.
And this is usually via
something we call the draft.
And that's a process
in and of itself,
and we're not going to
focus on that for the POC.
We'll just assume that
everyone has their 16 players.
Now, the core part of the
game is that each week,
you get to pick nine starters.
You pick a quarterback,
you pick two running backs,
you pick two receivers,
and so on down this list.
So out of your 16 players,
you pick nine starters.
So this leaves you with seven
players that are on the bench.
And those seven basically
are ignored for that week.
So there were some rules
about the deadlines for when
you have to pick your starters.
In essence, you've
got to pick them
before they play that week.
I'm going to skip over
the details of this
since they aren't really
important for our POC.
But just note that
there is a deadline
and that that means
we'll have frantic users
making last-minute
changes to their starters
before the deadline.
All right, so the next
key part of the game
is how does scoring work.
So you pick your starters,
and your starters
are really key to this.
Basically, every
starter scores points
based on how they do in
that week's NFL games.
All of this is based on
the official NFL stats.
And then your team
score is just the sum
of the scores for
all of your starters.
And you win that week if you
score more than other teams
in your league.
So just a quick
word on leagues--
typically, you
have 8 to 10 teams
in a league, 8 to 10 users
competing against each other
with their teams in the league.
But there are tens to hundreds
of thousands of leagues.
Now, every week,
you can also change
some of your 16
players via trading
with other teams in your league.
And I'm going to skip
over that for the moment.
We're not really going
to focus on that.
So there are a number of
parts of the puzzle here,
and we're going to focus
on just one for our POC,
and that's handling
team updates.
So as I mentioned,
each week, users
get to pick nine starters.
That translates to traffic
each week from users
to change their starters
and, for example,
switch in a player who is
currently on the bench.
And we expect to see
bursts of this traffic
before games start.
For example, users might
get fresh information
about player injuries, weather
conditions, actual team
lineups, et cetera.
And they'll probably want to
make last-minute updates based
on this new information.
We're also going to
assume that we're
handling this for
all users across tens
to maybe hundreds of
thousands of leagues.
So as you can
imagine, this is going
to generate quite a
lot of team traffic.
So let's switch to POC goals.
What are we going to set
as our goals for this POC?
Probably the most
important goal for our POC
is, can we handle the
expected team traffic?
So let's suppose that today,
we see bursts of maybe 5,000
to 10,000 QPS, so
update team requests.
And we may be struggling
to handle those bursts.
Maybe we're already running
on a sharded MySQL database.
So a core part of our motivation
for running on Spanner
is to scale easily
for our future growth.
Call it scalability insurance.
So we could pick maybe 2x
of our existing QPS burst,
or maybe 5x, maybe
50x for our POC.
From a Spanner perspective, it
doesn't really matter too much.
Internally at Google, we
have Spanner databases that
run many, many millions of QPS.
And it's a matter of
provisioning the right number
of Spanner resources.
For this POC, we're going
to pick a 5x growth.
So that means our
goal is to handle
traffic of around about 50,000
QPS of team update request
traffic.
I've added two other
goals to our POC.
First, we want to verify
that our read and write
latencies are in
acceptable ranges,
let's say under 5
milliseconds per read,
15 milliseconds for
rates, both at medium
and around about double
that for 99th percentile.
And the second
additional goal is
we want to understand how
quickly Spanner can scale up
if we need to handle
a burst of traffic.
Now, note that in Spanner,
we can choose a single region
or a multiregion configuration.
And the main advantage
of multiregion
is higher availability.
So you go from four
nines for a single region
to five nines for multiregion.
And the tradeoff is cost, so
a multiregion configuration
is going to be more
expensive and basically
have more replicas of
your data, and writing
will be a little bit slower.
So for our POC,
we're going to be
using a single-region
Spanner instance.
OK, so now let's
switch to our POC plan.
As we've discussed,
our main focus
is on team update traffic, and
in particular, handling bursts
of this traffic that
we typically see right
before games start as users
make last-minute changes
to their starters.
We're going to limit our
POC to the following scope.
We're going to use a population
of a million users, randomly
generated.
We're going to just focus
on team update traffic.
And we're going
to limit ourselves
to looking at week
1 of the season.
So we'll come back to
these decisions later.
The point here is that
when you're running a POC,
you need to fix many parameters.
And at some level,
they're educated guesses.
And they will often
evolve during the POC.
But you need to start somewhere
or other to get bootstrapped.
And the structure of our run,
our experiments in the POCs--
basically two steps.
Step 1, we're going
to generate and load,
a million users and
their initial teams.
And then we're going to hit
our database with 50,000
QPS of team update traffic.
All right, next, let's
talk about the tables
we need to set up
to run this POC.
So we're going to
have two tables.
The first is a Users table.
And the primary
key here is UserId.
This table also has a user's
name and email address
and other information
we might need.
May potentially including
information about how they
log in and authenticate to us.
We're going to gloss over those.
While getting the
details of this right
is critical for an actual
migration, for the POCs,
these issues often
aren't our focus.
And in this POC, we're going
to largely ignore them.
In effect, we're going
to treat this data
as basically a blob
of a few hundred bytes
that we have to carry around.
But the content of
these bytes isn't
going to impact the running
or the performance of the POC.
The next table is
the Teams table.
This is a bit more
interesting for the POC.
Here is where we store
details of a user's team,
so their quarterbacks,
their running
backs, their wide receivers,
and also the seven
other players on the bench.
I'm just putting
it on this slide
I've dropped some of
those other fields,
but we've already
talked about what
components we need to
represent a user's team.
So just slot them
into the schema here.
All right, so basically, we
need all of the information
that we need to capture a
user's roster in this table.
Now let's focus on the primary
key used by this table.
First, we need to have UserId.
That's pretty clear.
Now, I mentioned that
users play in leagues.
It's possible, and it's actually
pretty common, for a user
to play in multiple leagues.
So we're going to have LeagueId
as a second part of the key
so that we can keep
track of a user's teams
in multiple leagues.
The third component is Week.
Now, the NFL season
runs for 17 weeks
and, well, actually it's
going to be 18 weeks starting
this year, plus playoffs.
Now, we've chosen here
to capture a user's teams
for each week of the season.
Strictly speaking, we
don't need to do this,
but it's actually a useful
chunk of information
to have because it allows us
to track how a user changes
their team over the course of
a season from week to week.
And it potentially allows us to
do some additional validation
checks and potentially
some additional analytics
and analysis queries.
All right, two final
points on that schema--
first, I've set this up
as an interleave table,
so the Teams table is
interleaved in the Users table.
And this means that a user's
teams will be located together
with the user's data.
So it allows us to do efficient
joins between those two tables
if needed.
It also allows for easy
cleanup when we delete a user.
All of their teams will
be automatically deleted
because of this clause.
Now, in the particular scenario
we're using for our POC today,
we're not really going
to be running queries
where the interleaved
tables are going to be
important for performance.
However, just note that there
are many situations where
interleaved tables can lead to
significant performance gains,
both for reads and for writes.
All, right the second point I
want to emphasize is on UserId.
So this is a really critical
part of our primary key.
So UserId is here, the first
component of primary key.
And it's a critical part of
the primary key for both Users
and for Teams tables.
Now, in the previous
slide, we said
we were going to use
random user ID generation.
And this is a really
good way of achieving
a uniform distribution of
IDs across the key spaces
for both tables.
This is a recommended
Spanner best practice
and in particular
avoids hot spots
and makes scalability easy.
To explain why, I
want to briefly recap
an important Spanner,
concept that of splits.
I'm sure some of you are
already very familiar with this.
But as we shall see,
it's an important concept
to keep in mind as
we're running a POC.
All right, so in
Spanner, the primary key
of each table in a
database is partitioned
into chunks called splits.
So in this example, the
primary key is an integer.
And the first split ranges from
minus infinity to minus 100,
and the next split from
minus 99 to 3,000, and so on.
So the same basic things
happens for other types,
such as strings and floats and
for multicolored primary keys.
Now, each zone has a
copy of each split.
So each zone will have
a copy of split 0.
It appears in different
places on different servers
in each zone.
But the key point
is that each zone
has a full copy of the
key space of the table
and indeed has a full
copy of the table's data.
You can think of each zone
as a standalone replica.
And Spanner ensures that
each replica stays in sync
and has exactly the
same committed data.
So what's the role of splits?
First, splits are the basis
for distributing tables
across span servers.
And second, they form the core
part of an automated sharding
mechanism to balance
load across span servers.
So splits are not static.
They're continually on the move.
They're continually evolving.
So for example, if a split is
hot and receives lots of load
and contains lots
of data, it will
be split into smaller splits.
If two neighboring
splits are relatively
inactive for a long period of
time, and they're small enough,
they'll eventually be merged.
Now, it's worth emphasizing
that the starting point
for an empty table
is just one split.
So when load starts landing
on that table, all of it
is going to hit that one split.
In other words, all
traffic for that one table
will go to just three span
servers, one from each zone.
Now, suppose I have a
hundred nodes provisioned
for my Spanner instance.
Then my capacity when I
start with an empty table
is effectively 1 node
out of 100, or just 1%
of my total capacity.
Now, the good news is that
Spanner quickly adapts.
It can handle 2x increases
in load in a few minutes.
But when starting
from an empty table,
we need several rounds
of such increases
to get to full
capacity, and we'll
see this process in some
detail later in the talk.
All right, so let's
switch back to POCs.
And I want to talk
a bit about why
splits are important for POCs.
So they're really
important for performance.
You know, as we've
noted, splits are really
important for performance.
And if I have two databases
with exactly the same data
but different sets
of splits, then I'll
probably get
different performance.
If one database just
has a couple of splits,
and the other has a lot more
splits, maybe 10x or 100x more,
then we'll probably see
substantial differences
in performance between
those two databases.
So that means to get
repeatable results in a POC,
I need to set up similar splits.
Or to put it another way, I
need to have a warmup procedure
that I consistently use.
And without this, you risk
getting skewed results that
are confusing and misleading.
Now, as we'll see, doing a
warmup isn't that difficult.
It's mostly about
doing it consistently
to get consistent results.
All right, let's jump
to some experiments.
The first experiment is about
scalability and latency.
And we're going to start
with an empty table,
then load some data, and then
send some team update requests.
And we'll see the
effect of splits.
So we'll see effectively the
process of doing a warmup.
The second experiment is
about handling overload
by scaling up.
And the last experiment
is about handling
more expensive
analytics queries that
involve doing substantial
scans over the database.
We're going to look at the
performance of such queries
and how they relate to splits.
And we're going to use a
query to actually find out
which quarterbacks are the most
popular in our fantasy teams.
Let's start with the
first experiment.
As I mentioned, we're going
to start with an empty table.
We're going to load some data.
And then we're going to
send update team requests.
So the initial
load happened here.
The initial load was doing
large bulk writes in Spanner.
And they didn't really
show up in the QPS.
So the QPS with
this was very small
because we were sending large
sets of writes to Spanner.
So the QPS was
probably under about 1
QPS, just doesn't
show up on this graph.
About 10 minutes
after the load--
so we did the initial load,
waited for about 10 minutes,
and then we started
sending update traffic.
And as you can see,
our QPS capacity
increases fairly quickly,
reaching about 100%
after about 45 minutes, although
we do see some QPS variation.
Then it becomes very
stable after about an hour.
And so about an hour
after the start,
we're reliably
seeing about 55,000,
56,000 57,000 QPS of update
team traffic, all right?
Let's push this graph to
the bottom of our slide
to make room for a CPU graph.
And when we say CPU,
we're particularly
interested in CPU utilization
of high-priority operations.
So a strong recommendation is to
keep this below this 65% level.
Now, you can see that
CPU is growing over time
and that we stabilize around
42% to 43% CPU utilization.
So what's going on during
this ramp-up period?
Well, at the start
of this period,
all the load is hitting only a
small number of span servers,
and they're likely to
be running very hot.
So those particular span
servers are probably
running at 100% utilization.
And that's what's
limiting our QPS.
Now, many of our span
servers at this point
are going to be seeing
little or no traffic.
They're basically
going to be idle.
Now, the overall utilization--
so the overall
utilization at this point
over the entire instance is low.
Over time, we even out the
load, and more spans servers
see more load.
And eventually, this
load is balanced,
and we see an even spread of
the load across span servers.
So that pretty much explains
the growth in CPU utilization
and how that tracks fairly
closely the growth in QPS.
Now, early on, I mentioned
the initial load of users,
and it didn't show
up on our QPS graph
since the QPS was so small.
But we do see it
on the CPU graph,
and it's just a little
blip just before 2:30.
So one conclusion here is that
the initial load of user data
was just a tiny blip.
It didn't take long to do, and
it didn't use many resources.
And now we mentioned that--
earlier, we mentioned
that Spanner splits
are done based on-- the
load balancing is done based
on the size of data and
splits and the load, basically
CPU on each split.
And in this case,
our initial load
didn't have enough
data or enough CPU load
and wasn't running
for long enough
to really stimulate the split
and load balancing mechanisms.
So this initial load
didn't really load balance.
It didn't really
establish many splits.
It did a little bit, but
it didn't do too much.
And so the real warmup happened
when we added the update teams
traffic.
So if our initial load had
included much more data,
had taken longer,
and used more CPU,
then it's likely the
shape of our QPS graph
would look very different.
And we would have seen a much
faster QPS ramp-up, potentially
an immediate QPS ramp-up.
So this is something to think
about for our actual migration.
How much data will we
be loading initially?
And maybe we should
model that in our POC.
We'll come back to this
point a little bit later.
All right, let's switch
over to look at latency.
We've dropped the CPU
graph from the top,
and we've replaced
it with latency.
But we're keeping the underlying
QPS graph as a reference point.
So what we see is that
latency almost looks
like a mirror image of QPS.
Initially, latency
is high, and then
it significantly reduces
towards the end of warmup
as QPS stabilizes to
around about 56,000 QPS.
Let's dig a little
bit deeper into this.
The latency graph
actually has four lines.
It provides both 50th
percentile and 99th percentile
for both reads and writes.
And it's the 99th
percentile latency
that is huge at startup.
So note that the scale here
is actually in seconds.
So some of the latencies
were 99th percentile here
during startup are really huge.
Now, once we reach steady state,
and the warmup, is complete,
we see that latencies
are much lower, right?
They're about 10 milliseconds at
median, 19 at 99th percentile.
And reads are about 2
milliseconds at median
and around 6.6 milliseconds
at 99th percentile.
Now, it's a little hard to
see the behavior of latency
over here.
So I'm going to zoom
in and just look
at the latency in that
chunk of the graph,
so basically after
warmup's complete.
So we can see a
little more about what
are the variations here
after warmup's complete
and give a more complete
picture of latency.
So after warmup,
our median latencies
for reads and writes--
so these two, the purple
line here and the green line
here-- are really solid
at about 2 milliseconds
and 10 milliseconds
respectively.
99th percentile bounces
around a little bit
but is mostly under 6
milliseconds for reads
and 20 milliseconds for writes.
So these are pretty solid
numbers and fairly typical.
And note that we're running here
at about 43% CPU utilization.
All right, in
experiment 2, we're
going to consider what happens
if we overload the system.
So we're going to
crank up utilization
using a warmed-up database.
So we've already applied
our warmup procedure.
We've already established
all of the splits.
Our database is ready to handle
substantial amounts of traffic.
And we're going to crank
utilization up to over 65%.
And we're basically
going to do this
by reducing the
number of nodes to 12.
So that's in this chunk
of the graph here.
We can see we're running around
about 65%, sometimes over 65%
here.
And then what we want to do is
understand how quickly Spanner
adjusts when we add more nodes.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to increase the number
of nodes from 12 to 30.
And as expected,
the CPU utilization
drops substantially and
pretty much immediately.
But we're probably more
interested in the question
of what actually
happens to latency.
So to pack all of
this on one slide,
we'll drop the number
of nodes, and we'll
use CPU utilization
as our reference graph
and move it to the
top of the slide.
Now, let's add
50th-percentile latency.
And you can see
that 50th percentile
for both reads and
writes doesn't actually
change very much.
There's a little
bit of ripple here
to the left when we're running
at very high utilization.
But mostly, we're solid at
around about 2 milliseconds
for reads and 10 to 11
milliseconds for writes.
It's a much more
interesting story when
we look at 99th percentile.
And here, the
change is dramatic.
When we were running
at high utilization,
99th percentile
latencies were up
in the hundreds of milliseconds.
But after the increase in nodes,
they drop back by 10x to 30x.
So a couple of
things to note here.
First on the right-hand side,
we see that write latency 99th
percentile over on this
side of the graph--
write latency 99th percentile
is about 2x read latency.
But on the other side over
here, the two latencies
are actually very similar.
And the likely
explanation for this
is that the
latencies on the left
are dominated by
queuings effects,
not on the actual
operation executed.
The second note that the
CPU utilization dropped
when we increased the
nodes, and it dropped just
before about 8:15.
But the 99th percentile
didn't drop till a little bit
after 8:15.
So this 7 to 8-minute
difference is basically
the time for Spanner
to adjust and balance
the splits from hot span
servers to the new span servers
that we've added when we
increase the node count.
All right, the last experiment
is sample analytic query.
And basically, we want
to see which quarterback
is picked more frequently.
And this is essentially a full
table scan and an aggregation.
What we're going to do is
look at the performance
of this query right after
the initial data load
and then again after warmup.
And a critical
tool to understand
the performance of
these kinds of queries
is query explanations.
And we'll dig into this
in the next few slides.
OK, so when you run a query
using Spanner's Pantheon UI,
you get a page like this,
and the query is here.
Now, I've added an
additional hint for Spanner
to use extra parallelism, this
"USE_ADDITIONAL_PARALLELISM"
here.
And I'll come back
to this shortly.
For the moment, ignore it.
It actually doesn't have too
much impact on the first query
that we're going to run.
Now, what I want
to highlight here
is how to get to
query explanations.
So when you run a
query, you usually
land on the results
for that query.
But to see the
query explanation,
you need to click on
Explanation, which
I've circled in bright green.
When you click on that, you
will see an Explanation panel.
And that Explanation
panel has a lot of data,
so we'll need to zoom in to
see it in a bit more detail.
So here we are, zoomed
in to that panel.
Now, if we focus
on this panel, we
see that it's made up
of three subpanels.
First on the left, there is
a zoomed-in view of the plan.
So we can see the
"Serialize result,"
which is the top box
of the query plan.
The next is a zoomed-out view
that includes the entire plan,
although it's kind
of too small for us
to really read carefully.
And we can see this square
here that shows what's
included in the zoomed-in view.
OK, and on the right
is the third panel,
which includes lots
of stats on the query.
Now, in this shade
of green, I've
highlighted some
interesting stats.
Our query took around about
321 milliseconds to run.
This is 322 milliseconds to run.
And it consumed about 581, just
over about 582 milliseconds
of CPU.
So how can that be?
We'll dig a little bit
further into the plan.
And we're going to do that
by basically dragging down
this box and then clicking on
this bottom-most element, which
is the table scan.
So we've done that, and
this is what we see.
So we've dragged down the box.
We've clicked on Table Scans.
And what we see,
interestingly, here
is that the right-hand
panel gives us
the stats for the table scan.
And note that there
are two scan instances
in this particular case.
So these ran in parallel.
And that's why the query ran
for about 322 milliseconds
but consumed 582
milliseconds of CPU.
It also indicates that we've
just got a couple of splits
in the table.
So this first run of the query
we did just after warmup.
Sorry, let me
rephrase that-- just
after we'd loaded the
data, so before we did
the main part of the warmup.
Now let's run the query
again after warmup.
First, note that the
query only took just
over 100 milliseconds,
and it was 322 before.
Now we want to dig into
the table scan operation
at the bottom of the plan.
And here's what we'll see.
So we now have 77 executions.
So there's a bunch we
could discuss here.
I just want to hit
a few key points.
So the key message is that there
are more instances of the table
scan operation, which means
we've got more parallelism,
so the query is faster.
So very roughly,
the more splits you
have, the more
table scan instances
you'll see for this query.
So if the latency for this
kind of query is important,
then ensure that
your database is
warmed up before you start
doing performance analysis
on these kinds of queries.
Now, I promised
before to explain
a bit about what the
"USE_ADDITIONAL_PARALLELISM"
hint was about.
So this hint tells Spanner to
maximize available parallelism
when there are lots of splits.
And without it, Spanner will
limit the amount of parallelism
it uses.
And this is really a
protection mechanism
to ensure that one large
query with lots of parallelism
doesn't monopolize the
resources of a Spanner instance.
But in this case, our
query is not that large,
and we're interested
in making it fast,
so it's appropriate
to use the flag here.
But obviously, you need to
use this flag with care.
All right, so that's
all of the experiments
that I wanted to discuss.
But before I conclude, I want
to go back to the POC plan
that we mapped out at the
start of our discussion
and basically to do
a critique of it.
So here's the plan--
so this is an exact
copy of the slide
that we had earlier in the talk.
Now, some of the
limitations that we have
were kind of clear up front.
But some of the
experiments also helped
us to understand the
limitations of this plan
and some potential things
we might like to tweak
if we were to do it again.
So first, we saw that
the million active users
was kind of on the small side.
And it led us to a
quite small initial data
set with only a few
splits after the load.
So part of the issue here was
that in designing the POC,
we ramped up the QPS--
so we went from 5,000 or
10,000 to saying, OK now,
POC, we want to do 50,000.
We should probably have ramped
up the number of users as well.
Maybe 10 million users
or 50 million users
might have been reasonable.
OK, so next, let's consider
the scope of the POC.
So we ran just one
week of the season.
But the question is, will
this work in week 18?
So we'll have a lot
more data in the table.
Point-wise lookups
should be fine,
but scans will be
more expensive.
Finally, let's consider
how we structure our runs.
So basically, we generated load
and then ran our team updates
for week 1.
But what about the rollover
from one week to the next?
So potentially, it's
worth tweaking our runs
so that we generate
data over a full season
and actually do the rollover
of how the team for one week
is essentially
inherited from the team
from the previous week.
So the overall point
here is that in a POC,
we typically make
simplifications
of the production system and
just focus on core systems
and functionality.
And this is a tradeoff.
Fewer simplifications mean
that there's more work to do.
There's a longer POC.
And potentially,
we get overwhelmed
with complexity, kind of missing
the forest for the trees.
On the other hand,
more simplifications
mean we might skip or
miss important issues.
So it's kind of useful to
list out the simplifications
you make and critique them.
So I've listed a number
of the simplifications
we made in the POC here,
roughly in order of importance.
We've already talked
about some of them.
But one of them I
wanted to mention here
is that all of the latency
numbers we were measuring
were measured at Spanner.
And probably, we
should be measuring
some of those latencies
both at the application
as well as potentially
at the user side.
All right, I want
to briefly recap
some of the best
practices we've discussed.
So the first is to collect
reliable and repeatable
results, make sure
that your database
is appropriately warmed up.
It's good to have a
standard warmup procedure
and to use this regularly
as part of your experiment
protocol.
Secondly, don't run Spanner or
your apps too hot, especially
if you're taking
latency measurements.
So in general, we recommend
sort of 40% to 50%
is a good target for
Spanner utilization.
And third, get familiar
with query explanations.
These are a really
effective tool
for debugging and understanding
query performance.
OK, I want to make one
final comment on tooling.
And it's fairly common
in a POC to use data
from an existing database
and bring that into your POC.
And we've built a
tool to help you
move such data sets
from MySQL or Postgres
to Spanner automatically.
It's called HarbourBridge.
And in our POC, we could
have used this to move over
a set of users and their
teams from an existing
database to Spanner instead
of randomly generating them.
So HarbourBridge provides
the following functionality--
it ingests data from
MySQL or Postgres,
either using dump or directly
connecting to your database.
It builds a Spanner
schema automatically.
And this is something
that you can
browse and customize
using the Schema Assistant
mode of HarbourBridge.
It creates a new Spanner
database with the schema
and populates it with data
from the source database.
And it also documents what it
did with a detailed assessment
report.
So it identifies
issues, tells you
about features that
weren't mapped to Spanner,
and tells you about any
errors that are encountered.
All right, let me stop here
and take any questions.
Let me check.
Let me check on the--
let's see-- on the chat.
Where are we?
OK, so Thiago asked, "Why
is this only reflected
in the 99th percentile?"
Thiago, do you mind
clarifying that question?
Do you mean--
THIAGO TASCA NUNES: Yeah, sure.
NEVIN HEINTZE: --why is--
yeah, go ahead.
THIAGO TASCA NUNES: So yeah,
I was asking about the--
when you reduced
the number of nodes,
you kind of saw the effect
only on the 99th percentile,
but not on the other percentile.
So I was wondering why
is that only reflected
on the [? tail ?] [? ends. ?]
NEVIN HEINTZE: So
basically, when
you're running a system
very close to its limits,
many operations are still
going to perform OK.
But occasionally,
there are going
to be some operations that
are going to get caught up
and basically get descheduled
or don't get scheduled
at an appropriate time because
the system is basically really,
really close to the limit.
So it's not uncommon for
your typical operation
to still run fairly quickly.
But it kind of depends
on the queuing model,
and it depends on
lots of other things.
So for instance,
if all queries had
to go through a FIFO queue
that was centralized,
then we kind of expect that that
queuing latency would show up
for basically all queries.
But that's not the way
that Spanner works.
You know, Spanner--
you basically
are sending queries across a
whole lot of different span
servers.
And there's going to
be slight variations
in the loading of those
different span servers.
And so many of them
will be perfectly fine.
They'll be at maybe 50%,
55% utilization, maybe 60%.
And they'll be able to
handle your load just fine.
Some span servers might be
up at 70%, 80% utilization,
and maybe many of the operations
on those will be slower.
So if we push the
utilization up to 80% or 90%,
then I'd expect to see that
the latency at 50th percentile
might start getting affected,
or at least the latency effects
of the overload would
start pushing down
to lower percentiles.
THIAGO TASCA NUNES: OK.
Yeah, that answered my question.
Thank you, Nevin.
NEVIN HEINTZE: All right,
any other questions?
THIAGO TASCA NUNES: Maybe
I can ask something else.
NEVIN HEINTZE: Absolutely.
THIAGO TASCA NUNES: Did
you ever face a situation
where a customer
would like to model
a larger part of
the application,
not only kind of
this small scope?
And how do you deal with that?
NEVIN HEINTZE: So I
wouldn't say we've
modeled just a small
part of the application.
This is really a critical
And I think it's
quite common to pick
one of the most
important workloads
in your POC, so something that
is highest QPS, most latency
sensitive, most
important for users,
for example, most important
part of user experience.
So I wouldn't say we
pick a small part.
What we're trying to
do is pick probably
the most important part.
THIAGO TASCA NUNES:
Yeah, wrong word.
NEVIN HEINTZE: Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, I just
want to emphasize
we're not trying to make this
problem really, really simple.
It's we're trying to pick
perhaps the hardest problem
and then go dig into that.
You know, I think the challenge
of picking too many problems
is that the POC can stretch on
for an extended period of time.
But maybe that's appropriate.
Maybe there are
five or six issues
that you really need
to drill down into.
So at some level,
a POC can almost
morph into the actual migration.
And sometimes, you don't
really know where the POC ends
and the actual migration starts.
But my feeling is that you're
much better off having a fairly
well-defined POC,
picking what you think
are the really critical
parts of the system to model
and just focusing on that.
You know, there's nothing--
we'll just say this--
if a customer particularly
wants to model many parts
of the system, then sure.
I mean, that's something that we
would always support them with.
But it potentially can
consume a lot of resources
and take a considerable
amount of time.
So it's all about
focusing on what's
the best value for the
time and investment you
want to put into the POC.
THIAGO TASCA NUNES: Got it.
Thank you.
NEVIN HEINTZE: All right,
any other questions?
ROY FULLER: All right,
looks like there
are no other questions.
So I want to thank
you very much, Nevin,
for hosting this session.
And thank you,
everyone, for joining.
I will end the
recording right now.
Thank you all.
Have a great morning,
afternoon, and evening.
NEVIN HEINTZE: Thank
you very much, Roy.
ROY FULLER: Thank you.